so i see it time and time again people
saying they got their car for free
property pays for their car
what does it mean can you actually get a
car for free um the answer is
kind of yes if you're a small business a
property business
all of this applies to you so make sure
you watch the full video
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm gonna be
interviewing a tax specialist a property
accountant
where we're going to be talking all
things tax from capital allowances
stamp duty should you buy through a
limited company or as an individual
group structure what you can claim is
expenses what you cannot
all things tax use this video refer to
it regularly you're going to find this
really really helpful in your property
journey so firstly i just have to say
thank you so much joshua for coming on
the show yeah my pleasure thank you much
for bringing me on here
hopefully going to share so much
fantastic content today yeah now you're
quite a young guy
yep but just give me before we kind of
start hitting them with the nuggets and
stuff
give me a one minute insight to your
background and your story yeah
definitely so
um basically trained as an accountant
i've been doing accountancy for the past
kind of six or seven years now at least
um all the qualifications and about
three years ago i founded jsm
so we're a firm of property specialist
accountants so all we work with is
property investors like yourself and
your audience
yeah so i'm a property investor myself
definitely mentioned that because i know
what it's like
being a property investor so we can give
a better service to our clients
it's so important and a lot of
accountants don't understand property
investment yeah
and it's great i love your story as well
how you were an accountant
and you saw how much guys like me were
making yeah
right yeah watching youtube wow he's
made how much yeah yes let's get on that
yeah and then it's like i want to do
that now so you're
you're a property investor you're an
accountant first yeah and i always say
i'm
a property investor first and the tax
stuff comes second for use the other way
around
yeah it's been great seeing your videos
the content
got a lot of mutual connections we've
also been friends now i don't know a
couple years yeah
uh loosely and um so so all right first
big question is limited company yeah
there's so much talk around this please
tell me
if you're buying a property if you're
new to property
should you set a company up or should
you just buy it as an individual
i suppose the easy answer is it depends
right it depends on so many different
things
but i'm going to run through a couple of
them are kind of what you should be
aware of and what you take into
consideration
the main thing is what you're looking to
achieve for property and kind of where
you are now
where you want to get to so if you're in
a job now you're earning kind of good
money and by that i mean you're almost a
higher rate tax payer so you're only
kind of
30 40 000 pounds potentially and you're
looking for a very large property
portfolio
and you're not looking to leave your job
so you're looking at long term 20 30
years away before you actually start
taking this money out you don't need to
live off
you're happy in your job yeah then based
on that you're going to be battle from a
limited company
because your mortgage interest is going
to be fully tax deductible you don't
need the money to live off
you'll pay corporation tax at 19 on the
profits
whereas if you do the flip side of that
say for instance you hate your job you
just want to be financially free you
want three thousand pound a month to
live off free property
um and then you can tell your employer
see you later yeah
if that's more like you you're probably
better off in your own name because
mortgage rates are cheaper
and as long as you're not a higher rate
taxpayer or near the higher rate
taxpayer mark
the section 24 which you're going to
come on to isn't really relevant to you
because
you're going to still get 20 tax credit
on your finance costs
right and for anyone that's watching
this thinking what the heck are you
talking about yeah
so section 24 which came in just a few
years ago
what is section 24 yes a section is
called section 24 because that's the
part of the legislation that represents
essentially and broadly
prior to section 24 being introduced all
of your finance costs
would treat you just like any other cost
in business so it's fully tax deductible
so when you're paying your letting agent
100 pound that comes off of your profits
and the lower your profits the less tax
you pay whereas now that's changed
slightly
and finance costs are not taxable in
that way of
shape at all so if you've got 100 pounds
worth of profits usually you'll take off
your 50 pounds of finance costs leaving
you 50 good profit
and once you've paid tax right now what
happens is 100 pound profit
you get no tax relief for your finance
costs initially so you pay tax on 100
pound
if you're a higher rate tax payer you'll
pay 40 pound tax on that being 40
whereas now what also happens is you get
a 20 tax credit your finance costs so on
that 50 pounds worth of finance costs
yet 20 being a 10 pound so you're
actually 10 pound worse off in that
example
yeah that's a very simple way of looking
at it um and which kind of shows that if
you're a higher rate taxpayer you're not
getting tax relief
which is where limited companies have
become so much more popular
i think as well the key is to know the
differences
to know the pros and cons but then
ultimately
go to an accountant yeah and say look
what do you think is best for me but
it's really good when you can have an
intelligent conversation with your
accountant rather than just be like i
don't know what i'm doing
yeah and i think and i think for me
maybe this isn't the case
for you but for me i'm usually the guy
coming to my account
saying oh maybe we could do this maybe
we could just i'm pushing the boundaries
yeah and then the accountant's just the
person that's kind of telling me if
that's legal or not yeah
um i mean you're very very very creative
so um which is which which is great and
you're a property investor as well
talk to me a little bit about group
structure and i needed a video about
this
yeah so a lot of people are just getting
started they often set up a limited
company especially if they're doing high
cash flow activities
because a lot of people start off doing
that maybe rent to rent and other
strategies like that
with the goals of build up that asset
base doing developments later on down
the line yeah
and a lot of people kind of set these
companies up and they're not well on the
best way to structure it
so that later on down the line you can
use the wealth that you've created in
your cash flowing company
to use fund your developments to fund
your property investments whereas
usually you could loan them between the
companies if you had 100 000 pounds of
profit in your steel sourcing company
and you want to use that to buy a
property what if you were to
do an inter-company loan from that
company to your asset holding company
for instance
from a tax point of view there'd be
quite a few problems with that because
if you want to write the loan off repay
it
from a tax point of view you pay tax in
one company you might not get tax relief
in the other whereas having that group
structure in place
allows you to move the money around and
move assets around as well so if you've
done a development you want to keep the
properties
movement around without capital gains
stamp duty potentially even though
corporation tax as well
just because you've got that group
structure in place yeah whereas if it is
you that own the shares
in all the companies 100 none of those
are available
yeah so if you're starting out when you
are looking to build a serious business
empire using cash flowing companies to
fund
the asset holding companies definitely
look at a group structure yeah because
it's going to save you a shed load in
tax later on the line
right so you've got your company that
makes money yep
which is a trading company yeah which is
gonna and then you're gonna have a
company which is gonna hold wealth
yep right so what about someone
that wants to do rent to rent but then
they also want to do deal sourcing
would you recommend they have a separate
company or would you absolutely try and
keep that separate as possible
because especially rent to rent if
you're doing rent-to-rent hmo
from a vat point of view and even a tax
point of view that's still track
taxed as property investment yeah so
even though it's rent to rent it's taxes
property investment which is on a tax
return is completely separate
so you need to do two sets of accounts
essentially to actually make let us do
that tax return from an accounts
perspective
from a vat point of view as well deal
sourcing that's ratable
rent around hmo isn't yeah so if you
were to say
buy something a piece of equipment a
laptop or something
because you've got exempt supplies and
taxable supplies some of your v8 will
actually be blocked where your turnover
relates to the exempt supply
whereas if you had two separate
companies just put all of your machinery
through that all your laptops or your
phones and stuff like that where you
claim all your vat back
then you leave your rent to rent hmo
company as it is where it can't reclaim
the v80
yeah so overall you're about to reclaim
more of that from hmrc
i'm sure some of the viewers are like
what yes
what you know so maybe they have to
rewind and watch it back a few times
um v80 you mentioned v80 i've got some
of my students
that are doing deal sourcing yeah and
they're packaging and selling deals
and then they're successful yep and
within about six months they're like
holy moly i've hit the vat threshold
yeah
and then they say to me could i maybe
set up
another deal sourcing company and and
and then another
and i'm like no yeah just accept
that if you want to be a big company you
want to be a big player you're going to
have to go back registered at some point
yeah and there's pro
and if you've ever registered me when
you're you can claim that back from lots
of stuff as well yeah
so talk to me a little bit about v80 um
because some people might not even know
what it is yeah what does v8 stand for
so value-added tax okay
essentially it's a tax on sales that you
make so all of your outputs essentially
outputs is the technical term for sales
so on all of those where it's at
standard rate supply
you have to charge v8 at twenty percent
there are reduced rate supplies as well
so five percent
certain things and some are actually
zero rated or exempt
um so if you're kind of selling products
to deal sourcing you have to charge
twenty percent vat so if you usually
set a deal for three thousand pounds if
you want to keep your profits the same
you have to add v80 on top of that
so the end customer pays 3600 but on the
flip side
you can then reclaim v8 and all of your
inputs if you've got offices
telephones um laptops all of that kind
of stuff
that will also be v8 at 20 so you can
reclaim that back
it kind of evens itself out in real life
yeah and people that try and
put off becoming about registered you've
got to accept it to grow your business
a lot of people kind of see i don't want
to go v80 registers i'll just stay below
the 85 000 pound mark
yeah but that's such a limiting belief
it's almost damaging to their wealth and
their success yeah
whereas you know what go v80 registered
accept it
as part of doing business but if you've
got a half a million pound business
paying your vat it doesn't matter if
you're making that money so true joshua
and
for me as well when i started out in
business i didn't understand tax at all
yeah i don't know anything about tax
growing up uh as a kid no one taught me
about tax i'm gonna make my kids pay tax
even if they get pocket money
they're gonna put a bit aside for tax
yeah just to get into the habit of it
to put money aside for tax and um i used
to just be of the mindset
when i started out in business what
about making money not about saving the
tax
i changed my mind when i got hit with a
seven figure tax bill
when i started paying seven figures tax
yeah i'm like
okay i'm not happy about this i need to
i need to now get smart
and i think i personally think
there's two extremes of people there's
some people that are obsessed with
trying to save money yeah and then i
don't want to hit that threshold and
they remind me of people that are
you know when you go to university then
you're like i don't want to pay it back
so i'm just going to stay at a job for
less than 24 grand a year forever it's
like no
grow and just pay back anything grow get
that registered but there's other people
that are reckless and don't care about
tax and don't worry about saving money
who are also stupid
because they end up paying like lows and
lows in tax yeah what would your advice
be to somebody about how much time and
energy and effort they should put into
understanding tax yeah i'd say you've
got to have at least
a good understanding because still
accountants or accountants out there
that don't really understand tax too
much that aren't going to give you the
best advice you need to spend some time
learning about tax especially if you
want to grow your business yourself
fundamentally you've got to be your own
accountant large companies they're
finance directors
for a small company like most people
have you need to basically be that
finance director so you need to learn
accountancy and have a good
understanding of profit and loss balance
sheets
you need to learn about tax that said
you shouldn't focus on it too much
because
priority fundamentally your priority is
making money
yeah but making money has got to be
number one but then keeping and
maximizing the money you've got left
after you've made it
is number two so that is the way you do
that is through clever accounting
making sure you understand where your
costs going reviewing your management
accounts
and saving tax yeah so that's the way
people should look at it
what's the difference between tax
avoidance and tax evasion
uh a good quote about this is um what's
the difference between the two the
thickness of a prison wall
because tax avoidance that's legal tax
evasion is illegal right so if you're
doing tax
evasion you're gonna go to prison tax
avoidance is basically where using means
that are
perfectly legal to minimize the amount
of tax you pay so
always avoid tax never evade it right so
evasion
is where you're illegally not paying
taxes so that's where you're not
disclosing stuff you've got assets
offshore you're not disclosing them to
the authorities
cash in hand work that's tax evasion so
if you're doing taking cash earnings and
not reporting them
that's the stuff that hmrc come after
you for and
can result in criminal prosecution yeah
but then avoiding tax
i think i don't i actually think that
they almost the system doesn't almost
doesn't want you to pay tax in a way
because
they give you incentives yeah like for
instance electric cars
i mean dude talk to me about electric
yes well yeah the government kind of
do stuff that supports their agenda
obviously they're not happy with the co2
levels and the emissions going on so
they want more people to be in electric
vehicles yeah the way they do this at
the moment is to drive
um people to go through that through the
tax relief that are available so
electric cars have been tax efficient
for the past couple of years and they
still are
broadly if you buy an electric car for
your company brand new tesla porsche
taken something really nice like that
80 000 pound car you can fully write
that off as a company expense
when you get full tax relief on that and
then you can drive that around
personally
and pay next to nothing in tax so
porsche taking the benefit in kind
which is the tax that applies where you
use a company vehicle for your own
purpose
is about 800 a year being one percent so
for a basic great tax payer you're gonna
pay 160 quid a year
in tax for driving around a fully tax
deductible
electric car incredible it's almost like
it's a free
car yeah i mean we're getting an
electric car at the moment
um which which should be coming in the
next couple of weeks and i'm pretty sure
even the insurance is tax deductible
insurance servicing tires
everything absolutely everything it's
almost like a free car yeah it's just
when you when you've got a company
that's making that's making money and
you're having to pay taxes
which is incredible talk to me about
some of the things that people should be
doing yeah
and claiming back because i think one of
the biggest
reasons one of the biggest things people
make mistakes on with tax is they don't
know what they can and what they can't
claim back yeah or write off as
tax-deductible
so you recently did a very interesting
post on
facebook yeah of you and some of your
staff
and you're having a nice barbecue it was
a hot day of the year and it looked like
you're just having a nice party and have
a nice barbecue
but actually you weren't you were having
a work
yeah barbecue and you said in your post
having a
a tax deductible barbecue so you're able
to claim back
the barbecue and i was like this dude
like tell me
talk to me about some of the different
things that you can play about maybe
people don't know they're not aware of
yes 100 my rule of thumb is a lot of
accountants maybe say yeah you can't
claim if you can't come back they're
very kind of negative
i always say we'll climb try and claim
as much as possible if i can't think of
a reason or there's nothing
that hmrc legislation that says we can't
claim it
let's claim it yeah um yeah yeah the bbq
is a fantastic example so the way
that was each year as an individual
working for a company you've got
something called an annual events
allowance so it applies to
christmas dinners anything that you deem
so anything like management
says an annual event 150 pound a year so
you can use a 50 pound at christmas 50
pound in the summer
however you want to structure it it's
absolutely fine and probably when you
use that
it's fully tax lookable with a company
so all of the costs whereas then fully
tax deductible saving you 19 corporation
tax
and then you as a director as an
employee you pay no tax personally
on receiving that benefit from the
company so that's one to make
sure you're aware of another fantastic
one is the trivial benefits exemption
so the best way we tell people to use
this is if you're a director of a
limited company
you get 300 a year so for husband and
wife partner it's doubled
and you can use this in 50 pound
increments so we say every two months
buy yourself a 50 pound amazon gift
voucher or a store of your choice
as long as you can't then return that
voucher for cash absolutely fine which
most gift archers you can't
use the company card to pay for it and
then you can use that to buy anything
that you want
so that's 600 pound a year that's a
fantastic one to use
um and aside from that it's just making
sure that you claim as many costs as
possible
so training costs for instance their
taxes up to a lot of people that are
just starting out
um kind of get these and then maybe
think ah
a couple of years later they've actually
got their company set up you can claim
that still then so with
uh pre-trading expenditure you can go
back seven years
and any expenses you've encouraged in
those seven years you can claim on the
first day you start running your
business
so talk to me about what that looks like
so if someone comes to me
yep they sign up for samuel 365. yeah
they pay 95 pound a month yep that's a
thousand pounds a year
yeah how can they claim that back so
essentially say for instance it takes
them a year safer they've got other
stuff going on a year later
they actually make the move they find a
property they start getting income or
they set the limit company up
all of those 95 pounds a month for tax
purposes
are treated as if they incurred on the
first day their business started trading
incredible so i actually didn't know
that that's a good couple of thousand
pounds that they can then
get tax relief and they've got seven
years yeah seven years so basically if
someone does one of my courses
yep and they pay what about
if they have to come to a course what
about the the hotel bill
yep the hotel what about the dinner that
they had in the evening yes as long as
they had to stay overnight or something
out of their ordinary course
so someone comes to my training course
yeah they book a hotel
they have a nice dinner in the hotel
they pay
a hundred pounds or thousand pounds
whatever for the course
yeah and then they don't make a
successful property but they keep the
receipt
and then the following year they don't
and then the following year they don't
then the following the day and then
finally after six years
yep they set up a company and stopped
making some money they can then go back
take the receipts and then for the
course and claim that back
100 tax deductible yeah absolutely right
dude that's awesome and anything else
i've encouraged so a lot of people get
websites flyers
um you know dtv vendors that they're
trying to source all of that kind of
stuff as well that's all included in
that
one of the interesting things is we
always get gifts
for our tenants yeah so we'll get like a
christmas
um you know whatever it might be amanda
my wife sorts it out
and i will say to my wife it's it's
really good to do that because you keep
the tenants happy and you show that we
care
and i thought i wonder if it's tax
deductible yeah and i looked into it and
lo and behold it is
yeah i think there's a i can't remember
them i think it's up to 100 i don't know
you probably don't have the top of your
head
but i think it's up to 100 pounds or
something yeah you won't be able to get
them a car
yeah it's basically something small
enough that yeah like if you want to get
them some flowers and chocolates
whatever
yeah you can give it to them as a a taxi
adoptable gift yeah
offset against your profits so and most
people just spend it on their
out of their on their their personal
profits
yeah well even if you did spend an would
say you spent your own pocket if you use
your own card to pay for that stuff
that would actually go into your
director's own account so as long as
you've got the receipt for that
what will happen is you can still claim
it as a business expense and then your
company will owe you the money
so say for instance you spent 100 pound
on stuff yeah um you got 10 10
20 tenants that's 2 000 potentially your
company would then owe you that
so that would go to your director's loan
account and then say for instance you
didn't want the money now but you might
want it later
a year down the line that company can
then pay you 2 000 pounds
tax-free because it owes it to you from
those original expenses
amazing talk to me a little bit about um
when you're doing a property up yeah so
you buying a property you want to refurb
it
how does that work from a tax
perspective yeah so from a tax
perspective i suppose it's one of those
difficult grey areas
because there's a lot to it and you have
to look at each transaction
to see whether it's capital revenue so
capital that means it's improving the
asset
so if you brought a really kind of
run-down house no roof no nothing like
that
all of that expenditure that you incur
in order to get that property in a
condition when it can be let out
that's usually deemed capital so you
only get tax relief on that when you
come to sell the property later on down
the line
yeah whereas revenue expenses their
expenses that you incur
on a day-to-day basis in order to earn
revenue yeah
so what you want to do where possible is
get as many expenses through as revenue
so you get a tax relief now rather than
probably never because most people want
to sell their properties
okay so give me some examples yeah of
revenue expenses let's say it's been
five years and the carpets are a bit
shabby
yeah you replace the carpets is that
revenue yes so replacing carpets would
be revenue
it's a replacement actually the when the
first time you put carpets down
so if you've got a brand new house no
carpets down but you put them down
that's actually capital but replacing
carpets is allowable
yeah um replacing windows as well that's
revenue expense
boilers kitchens as well as long as
there's no improvement so if you've got
kind of an eight unit kitchen and you
buy to that and you put another eight
unit kitchen in
that's revenue but say for instance you
knock a wall through make it to a
kitchen diner and you've now got a 12
unit kitchen
we'd have to apportion it because only a
certain amount of that would be revenue
all of the stuff that makes that kitchen
better more valuable would be actually
capital
right right so as well i don't like
sometimes to talk about what i claim
back
as tax-deductible and stuff because i
don't want it to become about me and
yeah but get a big spotlight on me
like i wouldn't say welcome to my studio
it's my lounge yeah
like but but but you know i mean look
it's real i claim
you know i rent as you know several
houses yeah in this area
and there's certain rooms that they
could be classed as a dining room but
they also could be classed as a
boardroom yeah
and i claim back as much rent as i can
yeah i came back as much rent as i can
and you can
you can do that yeah essentially as long
as you're using this room for business
purposes um if you're a porsche san
francis 50
for personal use 50 for business you can
then divide
the total amount of rent you're paying
by a number of rooms and if you're using
say this room 50
you can claim 50 of the rent you
effectively pay for this room
yeah and the same with all the other
rooms as well yeah which is which is
which is great so yeah i think it's
about
you know you've got to do you've got to
make sure that everything you're doing
you do have professional advice yeah
because it could be and i've had the
you know the v.a.t man and and and and
the tax man
revenue check our books and come the
batman came it was a few years ago now
the really funny thing is we got um you
know a full report and not investigation
but the
batman came and it ended up that he owed
us 150 pounds
so i was like boom you know so because
you need to be very very careful about
this stuff but i think it's about just
knowing what you can and what you can't
do yeah and then and then doing it
properly
um so okay talk to me a little bit about
you've set up a limited company yeah
you've started trading
making a bit of money because a lot of
my students they'll set up a company
maybe deal sourcing rent to rent
whatever
then they'll come out of their job yeah
how do you
pay yourself through your limited
company
yeah so essentially there's a couple of
there's three main ways we like to say
you can pay yourself
so the first is taking a salary so as
your limited company is separate from
you you can't just take the money from
the business bank account
you basically need to do it in a formal
way so the first way is is a salary
so you'll get paid slips you pay income
tax national insurance on it just as you
would your normal employment income
we recommend people do this for a small
amount of income for this current tax
year it's about nine and a half thousand
pounds
if you are looking to take you pay
yourself take that out from your limited
company
as a salary and you pay the tax on that
not enough grand yeah so
you'll pay income well for most people
if say for instance you're you've got
another income for the tax year
that would fall within your personal
allowance being 12
570 so that would be tax-free from an
income tax point of view there'd be a
couple of quid work for national
insurance on it
yeah but then all of that salary is tax
deductible in the company
so the first so so basically the first
amount of money that you make if that's
your only income and that's about 12
grand
yeah you're not going to pay any income
tax on yeah that's right completely
tax-free your personal allowance
okay so that's why you're going to pay
yourself a small
um salary yeah to avoid having to pay
and get clubbed of taxes yeah that's
right okay then anything over and above
that
it makes sense to take either as
interest i know we mentioned
director's loan accounts early on so a
lot of people when they first start
their business up they put a lot of
money in to get it going
deposits of properties personal savings
and like i said earlier because you're
limited company yourself completely
separate entities
you can actually charge your limited
company interest so if you put 100k in
you'd only do that to get a return back
from somebody if you lent that to a
third party you're pretty charged in 10
12
so you can actually charge that to your
own limited company so on a hundred
thousand pounds
you could pull 12 000 pounds out as
interest which you'd receive by paying a
little bit you'll pay income tax on it
say 20
and then that's an allowable expense in
the company which means you're going to
get 19 corporation tax
relief so you pay 20 tax on it if your
basic rate
taxpayer maximum 19 corporation tax
relief
that's one percent tax that you're paid
on almost an infinite amount of income
because as your director's own account
keeps growing you can charge as much
interest as you want
yeah yeah that's great um okay
so in terms of tax efficient property
investing because this is a property
investment
channel buying through a company can be
tax efficient you can avoid section 24
but it just depends on the scenario yeah
one of the things that we
have done a lot of and also many of our
students have is service accommodation
yeah
which is like tax paradise because
there's so many advantages
to that strategy from a tax perspective
because you just talk me through
what that looks like yeah so service
accommodation
a lot of people actually don't notice
but service accommodation is better than
probably your own name on llp
it's one of the better ways to do it
simply because you can get something
massively valuable called capital
allowances
on service accommodation so that applies
to all the integral features the pipe
work
any ac units with that kind of stuff you
actually get tax relief on that
usually this is between say 20 and 30 of
the property value
so if you're buying a 200 000 pound
house using a service accommodation that
could easily be sixty thousand pounds
um and what this does is it tax
allowable expense
so if you you will not pay a penny on
tax until you've earned that sixty
thousand pounds in profits from your sa
business
because you've claimed those capital
allowances yeah and on top of that as
well when it comes to sell the property
you can get business has a disposal
relief you want to give it away
you get rollover relief so there's loads
of extra tax deductions available and
the biggest one of course would be
section 24 does not apply to financial
delay service accommodation
so you can still deduct all of your
mortgage interest right
so it's it's fantastic yeah tax
perspective and also from a cash flow
perspective
yeah because because people think well
if i rent out service accommodation i'm
going to make loads more money but they
don't pay loads more tax but actually no
you can make loads more money and you're
probably going to pay less tax yeah 100
i was speaking to somebody the other day
that said
they've been using their property of
service accommodation they've been doing
it
but they've been still been doing their
tax return because they do their own tax
return
as if it's a property business so
they're not they're still not claiming
their finance costs
um and they're still not getting the
benefits of running their property
service accommodation
but they actually are running at a
service accommodation yeah so speaking
to that client there was a massive
kind of mindset shift for them because
it's going to save them thousands in tax
just by actually getting those tax
benefits that are available
yeah really but that's why it's so
important to be educated yeah
and to know and to know what you're
doing um so for me
josh i've got as you know a large
property portfolio
oh i built up my portfolio quite a long
time ago first house in 2009
um they didn't bring in section 24 until
much later
yeah right so most of our houses
i only my personal name yeah and now i'm
doing more development deals i'm not
like accumulating properties like i used
to
however um one of the things we looked
into is
should we move our personal properties
into a company
now i came to the conclusion that we
probably shouldn't okay
but i get asked a lot from my students
should we move our properties from our
personal name
into a company yeah i'm sure you get
asked that question
as well yeah what would you say so i
suppose it depends on how many
properties you've actually got
so there is a way to move your
properties into a limited company
but it all depends there's a famous case
with a ramsey case which basically said
that
if you work more than 20 hours a week in
your property business you qualify for
incorporation relief
which allows you to move the property
business uh properties into a company
tax-free
because otherwise if that's not
available it's a market value
market value disposal so say for
instance you've got a capital gain on
their house prices have gone up
you would pay tax on selling their
properties from yourself do you limit
company
but you've not actually got the money
from that so you've got to find money
somewhere to pay this tax bill
and also there'd be stamp duty payable
as well based on the full market value
yeah that was the killer for me yeah so
if they're not available from a tax
perspective
it doesn't really make sense yeah um
that said the railways around it so
we've got if you work at least 20 out
20 hours per week in the property
business which tends to be most people
have eight properties you need
in order to really back that up um you
can incorporate without there being any
capital gains tax
and also if you run your business as a
partnership so if you've got husband and
wife running their business together
as a property partnership you can
actually do as long as you don't
they say about three years so that
you've got a justifiable partnership
you can then incorporate that into a
limited company without any stamp duty
either
so it is possible for people with large
enough portfolios
to get from their own name to a limited
company i guess it also depends how
badly you're being stung
yeah but and that was another thing is a
lot of our properties are hmos yeah so
the rent is high
and we were paying like 200 pounds a
month on the mortgage yeah the rent's
1500 pounds
yes it's not whereas if you've got
people that have got a lot of single-let
properties where maybe
their rent is 800 but their mortgage is
500. yeah
yeah so some landlords are in a position
where they're losing yeah they actually
have to top up the extra extra money
so i guess the answer would be probably
then it depends yeah
depends on the size of the portfolio but
with with your help but how much it's
going to cost
and then we looked at how much we're
actually going to save yeah
and it didn't make much difference yeah
so it wasn't worth the hassle
yeah because the fees to get across they
are expensive and if you've got kind of
low loan to values
very minimal mortgage payments compared
to the higher rental income yeah it's
probably not going to make sense
yeah and for most people watching this
if you've got one or two in your own
name
nine times out of ten it does not make
sense to transfer that to a limited
company that's what i usually tell
people i say if people come in i usually
say it probably doesn't make sense
yeah but speak to an accountant so if
people want to get in touch with you
um i would probably probably suggest
that they they go ahead and follow you
your youtube channel yeah where they can
find more videos and more content
so what would be the best way to do that
yeah so literally just type in joshua
tharby
youtube first and foremost we've also
got instagram facebook we've got a
facebook group
so many different ways but yeah just
head to the youtube channel when you can
find out more information there
awesome thanks so much for coming on the
show i'm sure people are going to be
very enlightened and
appreciate your time yeah it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you for having
me awesome
so there we have it folks joshua tharby
in the house sharing top tax tips
i think this i think this video is going
to be one of the most valuable videos on
youtube right now
so share the video share it with all of
your property friends because people
need to know this stuff
because so many people are losing money
on taxes when they don't have to
so share the video around in your
whatsapp groups with your friends
hit the like button if you didn't like
josh or if you thought he was a little
bit of a jerk
that's okay you can hit the dislike
button and um i know you're not going to
do that though
don't forget to subscribe you can
subscribe right over here and if you
want to see more videos like this you
can do that right over here
and i'll see you guys next time
you